when all Disney and Pixar studios just
merge already they are only separate
because they both love Legos also I
don't care if it's two of the most
successful studios of all time that's 44
seconds of two logos sometimes I think
I'm cursed and a narration in one day he
left with his guitar and never returned
the opening narek position of this movie
is so Beauty and the Beast that I now
have expecting at least one character to
end up with Stockholm Syndrome and she
learned to make shoes the role of the
great-great-grandmother will be played
by Daniel day-lewis
who not only learned to actually make
shoes in preparation for this role he
spent the last year being animated God
he's such a craftsman you know the last
time I was in a room with a woman this
old wrestling mask and feathers I'm not
sure hatred of music could or would be
passed down this many generations no one
in this family ever stop to ask if maybe
the real villain in that story they tell
every year is the music man and not
music itself the inside jokes and these
Pixar movies and movies in general are
becoming distracted no this really is
just the Mexican animated version of
Footloose right tewi brave mallanna
the good dinosaur frozen plains Zootopia
would it be weird to see a Disney Pixar
movie about a protagonist that was
exactly like their family and following
all the rules and was still a compelling
character the inside jokes and these
Pixar movies and movies in general are
becoming distracting
while I ponder this oddly casual death
being played for a LAN if I have to ask
was there any reason that Bell had to be
real I know this is a cartoon but the
candles and flowers situation here is
making me anxious not to mention all
that fruit next to the candles who wants
warm raw fruit and ordinarily I would
approve of the booze but again fire is
the one night of the year
our ancestors can come visit us we put
their folders on the ofrenda so there's
crossover expositional lecturing I feel
like I've seen this idiot dog character
played this same way in at least three
previous Disney movies that he or anyone
including Jesus and Bob Dylan could ever
properly tune a busting ass home a
beater guitar like that look at this
thing the strings are all different
distance apart from each other this kids
arnesto shrine it's kind of sweet and it
shows he really does get what the Day of
the Dead is all about just with his
personal hero as opposed to family but I
still can't remove a sin the fire safety
ignorance is a much bigger generational
problem for this family than their
hatred of music earlier his grandma had
super-hearing for anything resembling
music but here he is in the Attic
listening to and playing along with
music and no one in the entire house he
was it I will also take a sin off
because of how well this movie portrays
Miguel's genuine deep love of every note
a treat I've only ever seen in the very
best and purest musicians sure he can
sneak out but his family celebrates this
event together and they're going to
notice him missing I don't know how he
expects this plan to work the deal is
kind of stupid it's time he joined us
see the workshop watcher this is
exciting information but why does Miguel
think that this changes anything he
already knew that Mama Coco's father was
a musician right so why is he emboldened
to spill all this to his family
Kirt wrestling well I yelled his name a
couple times that's probably enough to
convince him to come back no need to
chase after him or anything how was the
guitar not crushed along with her nest
oh by that Tim Burton's Batman Bell that
kid is 65 pounds tops the only way that
lid moves here is if it's greased
granted we're about to experience
spirits and magic and supernatural that
guitar being in tune is going to end up
being the number one thing that bugs me
about this movie also koko and the six
strings what were there people who heard
a strum drawn rapidly here with
flashlights how that would Julio know
this sure they are able to get back and
forth today but they have no clue what's
happened to Miguel and this could
potentially kill him dead I see heaven
was designed by dr. Seuss hey so Christo
I wanted to take us in off for the
unbelievable animation about five times
already and the movies finally broken me
two cents off you mean to tell me I've
got to put up with in customs even after
I'm dead if the border agents know that
the bridge won't allow anyone to cross
over why do they even bother trying to
stop Hector bridge analytic old timey
bookkeeping skeleton guy would be
excellent at summer sense your family's
blessing and everything should go back
to normal
well you've got a do it by Sunrise who's
making up the rules on all this you had
his fingers back to the futuring should
we tell him there are no restrooms in
the land of the dead there are no
restrooms but there are pet allergies so
I'm letting you off with a warning
- is there law and order in the land of
the Dead all the time or just during the
Day of the Dead and regardless what's
the judiciary system based on do they
use the same laws as the living if so
what replaces the death penalty for a
particularly egregious acts
oh nice gag solid joke
why does he even have eyeballs sure her
spirit guide is a horn Panther dragon
okay but they said earlier the spirit
guides help the spirits find their way
not help find their missing living
descendants who were escaping in dead
land
why does a spirit guide even have any
human finding talents anyway who has
that
don't touch but why the Mizpah betta
taking flight Miguel just ran down the
road a few seconds ago and Pepita
apparently has his scent already
seriously they should have given this
dog a story credit this land of the dead
still celebrates the rich and famous
from life like Ernesto and his tower
party going on right now but this place
also bullies and mocks people who choke
to death in life and all I can think
about now here is where exactly Jimi
Hendrix would land on the social scale
here also they're mocking this guy for
choking to death but Ernesto gets a
celebrity pass against afterlife
bullying even though he died by falling
Mexican Liberty Bell you really want to
get to a Nesta there is that music
competition at the Plaza de la Cruz
winner gets to play at his par
not only is everything in this room
expositional fodder for Miguel's journey
there's an extremely convenient music
festival that would allow him to meet de
la Cruz also this is the second major
music competition in this movie and
while it's not the movies fault
the pitch-perfect series has really worn
me out on that kind of thing as a plot
device okay first of all you lending
your femur is on you I don't care if
this guy is the Homer Simpson of
borrowing neighbors never lend out bones
crucial emotive function
second of all how in the name of voodoo
witchcraft did you use any kind of twine
string tying device to secure this pipe
to this bone in this manner
look movie you can't have Miguel take
down a tomb guitar that hadn't been
touched over a hundred years and play it
with it being perfectly in tune and then
later feel me someone casually tuning a
guitar before playing it either guitar
tuning manners in this movie or it does
not pick one another sin off for the
movie again getting gifted guitarists
right every single one I've ever met can
wow me with their own playing in one
moment but sit in awe at the talent of
another player in the next classy Pixar
this is one of those jokes for the
parents studios like to sneak into kids
movies but in this case the kids will
actually get the joke which is
concerning
chicharrón waits to Yoda until the exact
moment Hector and Miguel show up just so
Hector can explain how that works
shouldn't the tequila be running through
Hector's skeleton and hitting the floor
I never thought I'd say this but Barbosa
from Pirates of the Caribbean is a more
believable dead guy wait what happened
he's being forgotten ooh okay so he's
living in a hammock and this part of the
dead land for those who never get their
picture put up during day of the dead
fine
but now that he's been entirely
forgotten he disintegrates so many
questions but chief among them who the
was thinking about this guy in the
last couple decades but not putting his
picture up cuz that guy is a douche when
there's no one left in the living world
who remembers you
you disappear from this world we call it
the sign of death cool and then what
happens after final death final death
land how many layers are there Oh
memories they have to be passed down by
those who knew us in life hmm well I
find that to be simple my memories
aren't good enough or powerful enough
unless I've talked about them ad nauseam
around enough friends that one of them
still remembers the stories also this
movie that is clearly pro-family fine
that is cool is so pro-family they risk
alienating people who don't have a lot
of siblings or those that choose not to
have children a minority yes I'm just
saying movie is not right suggesting I
should have kids and tell them all my
stories and if I'm honest kids give me
panic attacks but I still have good
stories let's talk about how the land of
the dead but not final Dead has
electricity if you all don't play one
song how can I call myself a musician
never stop Britney Spears dude awesome i
legit applaud this movie for having
Miguel kicking ass in his first
performance I get it and I love it but
when he spin dances six feet left of the
mic his voice continues being projected
as though he were still in front of the
mic and I'm sorry I can't let that slide
you bothered to put a microphone in dead
land and carry that through movie boy
have you looked at the stage of the
arena you're in Jesus lady he's wearing
the same outfit is when he left you guys
huh apparently pretending to be dead
gives you a zoom and enhanced superpower
even Pixar is an immune to shoot warning
in a protagonist argue and separate
before the climax of the movie cliche
gah cuz every movie had to do this
flying magical beasts combination
somehow can't get through a narrow
staircase in the land of the dead now
honestly clueless on the rules of this
movie and that's a problem worth
mentioning even though the average
viewer glosses over it family's supposed
to do support you but you never will
sick bear and kid well I like a sound
let you run off to your concert even
though I have a magic spirit animal that
could easily intercept you on the other
side of this alley wait they're using a
super powerful spirit animal to surfing
hors d'oeuvres deadmau5 nobody notices
this this works
forget the rest back from security do
they honestly have time for polo isn't
Miguel on a mission that is
time-sensitive and confined to a single
day I am sorry to see you go me again
it's at this point that movie
prematurely gives the twist away
considering there's 30 minutes of
runtime left and there's no way this
will actually work that's me that goes
toast and does in a gross movie look in
the movie Donnie Darko poisons the drink
hang on this exact clip is playing right
now I'm really starting to think they
should change the name to land at the
plot coincidence I would move heaven and
earth for you me I'm eagle I guess
ernesto has just been carrying that
poison around in a suitcase this entire
tour waiting for a chance to use it if
you murder a living human kid in the
land of the dead does he die or what he
never died the first time so we can't
die a final death here which means that
best-case scenario he just comes back
here as a proper skeleton no my daughter
she's the reason you wanted to cross the
bridge I just wanted to see her again
but I neglected to mention the sole
reason that I've been trying to make
this happen during this entire movie
until now I mean seriously this movie
would have been over a long time ago if
Hector had said anything about his
daughter I wish I could tell her that
her bout was trying to come home Hector
plays the pronoun game with Coco just so
we can wring a little more tension out
of this reveal my role Coco's even after
the realization that they're related and
can easily rectify both of their
situations by finding one of those
plentiful petals and getting Hector's
blessing these assholes sit around this
cave instead of searching for a way out
why was he so stupid and normal looking
and stupid then god I hate this dog does
everything here and have to be
skull-shaped
he left this
try to go home to you in golf ball but
delacruz murdered him it's true goddamn
it then why didn't you find a way to
tell this to a medal - the whole time
that you were in the land of the dead
this entire movie could have been solved
with simple communication you will
return home no more music
family comes first what oh did you oh
not only is this a terrible way to
convince her nesto to hand over the
photograph technically miguel is a
melda's great-great-grandson so
everything about this scene is kind of
wrong like basically all Pixar movies
this film devolves into a garden-variety
chase scene at the end
fortunately for Imelda in the movie
security takes a Blues Brothers the
intact of advancing on a performer on
stage you're going home you're not going
anywhere and that's on Miguel for taking
his sweet-ass time to grab that pedal to
keep your memory alive
billon expose it to zeebo plan for all
the world to see cliche look we all knew
there would be another spirit animal X
Mok in a moment here but the poppy to
this long somehow even though the
cameras are inside the stadium there's a
perfectly frame shot of the killing bell
for everyone to see
damn it dad's classic move of ordering
the kid to stop but not pursuing him is
still not working don't know what keeps
going wrong please if we forget him
he'll be gone forever
ah eternal sunshine I knew this movie
was basically an amalgamation of five
other movies and until now I only knew
four of them Back to the Future
crossroads
heaven can wait The Passion of the
Christ obviously and finally Eternal
Sunshine of the spotless mind yeah glad
that's solved I should remove a sin for
the scene being so emotionally powerful
but since I can't see what I'm writing
while ugly crying I'll just let this
encounter do what it wants
[Music]
just what we needed a pop remix of a
song we've heard roughly 54 times
already in the movie just keeps going on
doesn't it he to live gotta still to eat
tell you all about it when I got the
time
[Music]
let me help Thanks what did a cruise
always say carpe diem seize the day
he doesn't seem entirely dead and you my
great-great-grandson are meant to be a
musician
[Music]